we have a voicemail number 2192 David P
here's someone who says it was wrong for
me to go to England last week
um because there are there are poor
people uh this is this is tough listen
to this
so on the recent email
I demonstrated
my disappointment slash anger slash
something else
about the fact that you
went to England yep
I don't have an issue with England
I just have an issue with
how do you actually relate to the poor
people do you actually think I or the
people that you supposedly care about
can afford to go to England
or France or Spain or all these places
which are
Out Of Reach for many people
so the point of being angry was
you know
couldn't you maybe subtract one of those
trips and maybe donate it to a
charity that
actually helps the people that you claim
to care about which I'm sure you care
about but it's not very well
demonstrated but the fact that you know
uh since I've been following you you've
gone to I don't know maybe three or four
or five or six trips that are pretty
expensive
so listen anyway
um I it's just like
should I
who who gets to go on trips okay I
shouldn't go on any trips that not
everybody can afford
I should donate all my money to charity
what about a lawyer who says hey I care
about poor people so I'm going to do
some pro bono work but sometimes I'll go
to London with my family
if that lawyer really cared about the
poor people he does pro bono work for
he can't go to England either I mean
this is this is really just kind of a
weird path to go down
and
um you know I know that there are some
people in my audience who are going to
write to me and say David you don't have
to justify anything to that guy you you
do what you want to do you do the show
you want to do if people find that you
are not aligned because you went to
England with thinking everybody should
have health care then they can choose
not to listen but it's just
what are we doing guys what are we doing
and what what trips would be acceptable
right I mean should I go to uh uh should
I go to
should I go to the uh Hudson New York
instead of England as the place I go
because it's more accessible I don't
know I don't know but at least this
person thinks I did something very very
wrong all right we have a great bonus
show for you today Mike Pompeo says he
won't run in 2024. Joe Biden has signed
an executive order to improve access to
child care and the South Dakota Governor
Christie Christie gnome Christy gnome
says that her two-year-old grandchild
has several guns what the hell is going
on in South Dakota and by the way I may
soon be going to South Dakota speaking
of trips I'll talk about this on the
bonus show today don't miss it sign up
at joinpakman.com